My name's Brent Dicesare,
and I'm half of WD Detailing.
And today we're going to be cleaning
a super-moldy car
that has grass growing in it, mold, water,
and all of the above.
It was absolutely disgusting.
First, we put the ozone
machine inside the car.
It basically pumps oxygen
to the third degree into it,
or ozone,
and it suffocates the
bacteria and kills it.
And then we'll pull the seats out
after we do the ozone treatment,
so we can actually
get to all of the spots that we need to.
And then the first thing
that we'll do is vacuum it,
try to get all the
debris, or, in this case,
the mold and the water out of it
so we can really get in
the car and work on it.
So, here we're working with
where all of the water ended up going.
The water was only on half of the car,
and I think that's because of
where the leak was located.
So what you're looking at right now
is us vacuuming up all of that water.
The last time that this
car was plated was in 2015,
so it ended up sitting
for the last six years.
And just about five months ago,
the owner noticed that there was
an issue with the sunroof
where it wouldn't close all the way
and water was continuously
getting in there,
but we've never seen
anything like this before.
For a car like this,
it's actually recommended
to remove the carpet,
throw it away, and replace it.
But for some reason, in this specific car,
it was stapled down completely
to the point where if we
were going to remove it,
it wasn't going to go back in
and sit the way that it would need to.
For this car,
it was definitely a different process
than when we would normally extract a car,
because the carpet was basically stained
with that green mold.
And we had to try to figure out a way
to push it out of the fibers of the carpet
and see if the carpet would revive
to the white color that it ended up being.
So the first thing that we did,
which we normally would not do,
is use the Tornador attachment,
which is compressed air
that shoots out in a circle,
like a tornado almost.
You have a little compartment
where you put all-purpose cleaner in
mixed with water, so you dilute it,
and you attach it to an air
hose on an air compressor.
And it really gets into
the fibers of that cloth
and kind of blows out anything
that might be in there.
So we blew out the entire carpet with it
after vacuuming it.
And then we'll go ahead
and we'll use our extractor soap on it
and spray a healthy amount on there.
And we'll actually use the extractor,
which shoots hot water into the carpet,
to get the carpet a little bit more wet,
because when we use our drill brush,
we want to try to reduce
the amount of friction
that we're putting into the carpet.
Because if there's too much friction,
if it's not wet enough,
then it can actually damage the carpet.
We'll use our drill brush
to agitate all of that soap.
So we'll go over it a few times,
get it really into the fibers.
And then we'll use our
hot-water extractor,
which only has water in it.
We don't ever recommend
putting any kind of soaps
or anything in your extractor,
because when you're blowing
the water into the carpet,
you want to suck everything out,
and if you have soap in it,
it's just going to add more to it
and it's not going to be completely clean.
I actually filled half of
a Shop-Vac full of water.
So I think I actually got
probably 95% to 99% of the water out.
When you do the doors, it's the same thing
as doing any of the other
plastics in the car.
In this case, we used Triclean,
which is made to kill bacteria
and all that stuff inside of cars.
While most all-purpose
cleaners do kill bacteria,
we wanted something that
is a little bit stronger.
Especially because in this case,
there's a lot more mold
than you would normally
see in a regular car.
And then use the Tornador attachment
or some soft-bristle brushes
and really get in every nook and cranny
and make sure we clean it up.
So, for this part,
he's actually drying off the door
and getting all the liquid
out of the nooks and crannies.
So that is the Tornador attachment,
but that's a different one
than the one that is used
for specifically cleaning.
So this Tornador attachment doesn't have
the canister that holds
any kind of cleaner,
and this one just blows out air.
So you use that to get
into cracks and crevices
where you normally couldn't with a brush
or with a microfiber towel,
or you use it to get under seats.
When we do leather seats
that have been sitting in mold,
the first thing we do
with any seat is vacuum it
just to get any kind of debris.
Especially in the crevice
where the bottom and the
back of the seat meet,
we'll use an all-purpose cleaner
or a leather cleaner.
They're two different things.
A leather cleaner is more suitable
for high-end leather.
And then he'll spray it on there,
use a Colourlock brush.
So it's a really fine, strong brush
to get into all of the pores of the seat.
When we're cleaning leather seats,
we don't use too much pressure
just because you don't
want to damage them.
You could leave scratches,
you could tear them.
Spray it again, use the
steamer to kill any bacteria,
and then wipe that away too.
When we do the wheels, the first thing
we like to do is pressure wash them off
and get any of that initial dirt
or grime off of them.
We have some heavy acid that we'll use
if it's really bad,
but we don't use it on painted rims.
And then we'll go ahead
and we'll agitate it with a brush,
and we'll use a few different brushes
to really get in both the wheel well,
on the tire, inside the rim,
and the drum of the rim.
And then we'll go ahead
and pressure wash it away.
So, for the exterior,
because it had been
sitting out for so long,
over time if you don't clean it,
grime will get attached to the paint
and start growing mold.
Because we did the
exterior of the car first,
we weren't too worried
about water getting in,
since it was already full of water.
So we just went ahead
and we pressure washed everything out.
We put paint-safe degreaser
all over the paint
because it just had a really thick layer
of both mold and grime on it
that wouldn't just come off
with an initial pressure wash.
We let it sit for about
two to three minutes,
and then we pressure washed it again.
And then we'll go ahead and
we'll use the foam cannon.
So, the foam is just a car soap,
and you just put it into a foam cannon
and you attach it to your pressure washer.
It acts as a lubricant for
any dirt that's on the car.
So when you go to wash it,
you're really minimizing
how much scratching can
happen to the paint.
And then we'll go ahead
and we'll use our microfiber mitts
to wash it and then spray it off.
The absolute best way to store a car
if it's going to be outside
is with some sort of car cover or a tarp.
That way, no water is going to get
on the top of the car
and find its way into the car.
It'll keep the paint clean
and away from all the elements.
If it's going to be a car
that you're not driving
for extended periods of time,
you still want to look in it
and make sure nothing's going wrong,
because seals can give.
And if they do and
water starts getting in,
then that's a whole world of problems.
So the best way to stop
mold is to be proactive
and check on your car before
it actually starts growing.
When it comes to detailing,
I believe it's best to
maybe get a full detail
once to twice a year, maybe three times.
I always tell people to vacuum it,
if not every few weeks,
at least once a month.